[تصفيق]
في البرازيل وتحديدا في مدينه سلفادور طقس
فريد لتقديم احد اكثر انواع الطعام شهره
في المدينه انه الطبق الاكاراجي
مدينه سلفادور الواقعه في شمال شرق
البرازيل وثالث اكبر مدنها من حيث عدد
السكان توصف بانها مدينه السعاده نظرا
لوجود العديد من مهرجانات الشوارع التي
تقام على ارضها
واحده من هذه المهرجانات يتعلق بوجبه
الاكاراج الشهيره
كعكات صغيره جلبت سابقا بواسطه الافارقه
الذين عاشوا على ارض سلفادور تجهز هذه
الوجبه حصرا بواسطه نساء المدينه ولا
يبيعنها للزبائن الا وهن مرتديات لباسا
ابيض اللون
النساء المتخصصات في اعداد هذه الوجبه
يطلق عليهن البهيانس ومعظمهن من اصول
افريقيه
مكونات الاكاراجي عباره عن دقيق
من الفجي
دان بزيت النخيل لقد بدات بطبخ ذلك منذ 25
عاما حتى قبل ولاده ابني طهارت هذا الطبق
لكن الان اصبح شيئا اساسيا في حياتي ولا
استطيع العيش من دون ان اقوم بتحضيره كما
انه يساعدني قليلا على جلب بعض المال
[موسيقى]
طبق يعشقه البرازيليون ويقبل عليه السياح
ايضا لمعرفه سر ادمان البرازيليين على هذه
الوجبه
[موسيقى]
وقد تم طاعه بشكل صحيح انت كل يوم لاكله
طعمه لذيذ جدا
تحضير الاكراكي مهنه متوارثه تنتقل من
الام الى بناتها ومن جيل الى جيل لكنه
هناك طبقا اخر ملازما لهذه الوجبه انه طبق
الفاتابا
للحصول على طبق فتاب جيد انت بحاجه الى
الجوز والكاج وزيت النخيل وحليب جوز الهند
والخبز وماذا ينقصنا لتتم العمليه بنجاح
ينقصنا سيده من بهايا تعرف كيف تحرك
الوصفه جيدا
في ولايه باهايا حيث تقع مدينه سلفادور
الطبخ التقليدي هنا غني ومتنوع للغايه
ويعود الفضل في ذلك للفتره الاستعماريه
فهنا اكلات افريقيه وبرتغاليه وهنديه
وغيرها من الوجبات التي يتخطى عددها
الخمسين طبقا
النساء المتخصصات في اعداد الاكاراجي يحضن
بتقدير كبير هنا وتحتفل المدينه بهن سنويا
في مهرجان كبير
2300 امراه ارتدينا الابيض وحملنا الورد
وزينا سواعدهن بالحلي كانهن في يوم عرسهن
يمشين عبر شوارع المدينه في مواكب
احتفاليه راقصه
حتى يصلنا الى الكنيسه ليتلقين مباركه
الكهنه
لا تبقين واقفات اجلسني سوف نقوم بخدمتكن
شكرا
[موسيقى]
ينتهي الاحتفال وتعود سيدات الاكاراجي مره
اخرى لممارسه عملهن واسعاد سكان المدينه
والسياح بهذه الوجبه المفضله
[موسيقى]